are you banking some extra sleep right
now don't forget we spring
forward for daylight saving time it's
coming up this weekend
sunday march 14th clocks will move ahead
an
hour at 2 a.m sunday which means we'll
be losing that one
hour of z's none of us need to lose
sleep this morning we're trying to get
some
ideas on how to cope with that loss of
sleep because let's face it mondays are
hard enough
hector mejia is live with a few health
tips from some local experts
i guess exercise is known to help give
you a good night's sleep what else can
we do
hector a lot more hey there sherry good
morning yeah
just besides monday any day of the week
is hard when you don't have enough sleep
and no one wants to be in a terrible
mood on sunday or monday tuesday and any
of the other days that come next so
joining us live we have dr
jackie absal here to talk to us how
physical therapy can play a role in
getting ready for this time change a lot
of people are dreading it
yeah absolutely so physical therapists
are well equipped to show you exercises
to kind of get back to exercise routine
and exercises have been shown to improve
sleep quality
especially during times of sleep debt
which is mean like a little bit of
restricted sleep schedule that might
come around
during daylight saving time interesting
you bring it up because we have some
exercising going on right now
absolutely so charlie's over here doing
some elevated push-ups great exercise to
get back into the work your upper body
if you haven't done push-ups in a while
he's in his uh 300
yeah that's uh 497. yeah so he's at 400.
counting no one's counting so we have
keira doing the recumbent bike here
great cardiovascular exercise
wonderful excellent form absolutely
looks great gets your heart rate up and
down really nice
and then walk to the right i got right
over here it's really not really an
exercise he just wants to show the
biceps off to the camera
and uh they look fantastic by the
exercise called the face pull works your
upper back your back your shoulders and
kind of gets you in shape for uh
for beach season coming up so all right
so what are some ways to trick your body
into believing that the uh
time change never even happened yeah so
an easy way to do that is expose
yourself to a little bit more sunlight
in the morning
so maybe get out for a walk maybe turn
the lights on a little bit sooner and
expose yourself to sunlight so because
light is what our body uses to kind of
uh channel our natural natural clock
that we have and it makes the time
change not feel as dramatic we were also
chatting a bit earlier you were telling
me uh even though a lot of people are
dreading this
it doesn't take a whole lot for your
body to get used to the time change
no so so rule of thumb is if for every
one hour of time change you only take
about a day to get
used to it so with that it's natural for
our bodies to kind of get used to it
over time don't dread it too much
kind of go about your natural normal day
and it'll change by itself
so basically that day will be sunday so
watch out for any people out on the
roads with road rage or at the grocery
store maybe being rude
yeah absolutely but there are also some
people that might wake up early and feel
really refreshed so maybe some nicer
people on the roads as well
like us absolutely all right thank you
very much so
we have more to talk about and also for
those who have not worked out in a long
time or just in a few months
how can you get back into the routine
safely we'll be talking about that
straight ahead
at 6 30 for now reporting live hector
mejia oh hey guys
so look at all of this equipment there's
a lot to work out here so
i don't know what do you guys think what
should i try next oh
the trx bands yes
i say do dead weights just you know get
get on the bench and just do dead weight
lifting hector's like white
actor let's do it i think i'll do some
of that it's
like i'm gonna sit down well i'll show
you guys i'll show you guys
at 6 30. maybe we'll have a surprise
maybe maybe not sounds fun that guy's
still doing his push-ups yeah
been going strong since 4 30 this
morning yeah he's working on it but
hector should just throw in some tai chi
does anyone have the experience of one
day to adjust
to daylight saving i wish we don't know
where that came from that's too hard
yeah
you know i asked myself why do we do
this yes
you know no it seems like if you do a
poll no one wants to do this anymore so
can we just get this over with you and
we ask that question until the clocks go
back
in the fall so i believe the nevada
legislature's even
considering something like this aren't
they but they have to only if california
did it but
we got to keep in mind that uh it's a
federal law
yeah so it's it's really not going to do
anything but i guess
write your congress person right yes
i put a post on facebook a lot of people
are saying i'm over daylight saving time
you know let's just let mother nature
handle the light
right she can take care of it herself
she gets the sun up she lets the sun go
to bed
and it all happens naturally without
having to mess with our clocks i know it
well